okay there's one more angle to the Brett
Kavanaugh Fiasco that I do want to talk
about today despite the fact that Brett
Kavanaugh was clearly lying during the
hearing with his accuser Christine Blasi
Ford last week despite the reality that
we all should understand that this guy's
completely and totally unfit to be on
the Supreme Court
it's still very possible that he will be
the next Supreme Court justice but there
might be I'm like really looking for
some kind of silver lining or upside
here there might be an upside to that
happening before the midterm elections
in just five weeks which is that there's
a new poll which claims that voters will
punish their senators if they vote to
confirm Cavanaugh there was a poll
conducted by change research which says
that 51% of voters are less likely to
reelect their senators to vote to
reelect their Senators if they vote in
favor of confirming Brett Kavanaugh 50%
also said that they would view the
institution of the Supreme Court as less
credible if Brett Cavanaugh is confirmed
these aren't overwhelming numbers it's
like a very slight majority within the
margin of error but the point is that
when control of the Senate hangs in the
balance for Republicans when there are
many races that are going to be really
close there's a risk if you're a senator
who votes to confirm Brett Kavanaugh if
you're up real for re-election that the
voters who are going to vote for or
against you are not going to be pleased
and in fact this is a time when the
campaign finance system we have should
be used to our advantage and what I mean
by that is I think the campaign finance
system we have is a disaster you know
that if you pay attention to this show
but right now this is the system we have
money should be raised immediately
millions by a super PAC that will do a
blitz of ads targeting senators who are
up for re-election in November and who
vote to confirm Brett Kavanaugh I want
to change the system we have but right
now use that system to do something good
gather as much money as you can build up
the war chest this week so that as soon
as the vote happens the TV ads can start
immediately your Senator Lindsey Graham
voted to confirm accused serial sex
assault or Brett Kavanaugh to the court
vote him out this November because we
know Republicans don't care about the
sexual assault and I have a poll that
will
tell you that in a second but if there
is going to be something that could kill
Cavanaugh's nomination it's not going to
be the moral outrage over what Cavanaugh
did or didn't do we know they don't care
about that it's going to be Republican
senators that want to keep their seats
if the polling starts to show that their
seats are in jeopardy if they vote to
confirm Brett Kavanaugh you actually
might see some Republicans say well hold
on a second here hold on a second here
Jeff Flake is retiring right but all of
a sudden you have other Republicans who
are running for re-election if they
think a confirmation of Brett Kavanaugh
will make them lose their seat they will
oppose him because you know what in the
end Trump's gonna get a different person
up there
Trump's going to get someone in there
that is the way that you might be able
to prevent Cavanaugh from getting on the
court I mean 50 percent or so saying
that they would be less likely to
support their senator for reelection
that doesn't sound all that promising
but you have to remember that's
nationwide right so if you take a look
at the states that have a Republican
senator but they're more left-leaning
like Maine with Suzanne Collins or
Alaska with Lisa Murkowski I think
that's where you have a chance because
it's not fifty percent there it's
probably significantly higher that's
exactly right and this is the way if if
there is a way forward to successfully
block this nomination it's going to be
the people that Pat name's Susan Collins
Murkowski there are others that we could
talk about make them afraid of losing
their seats and make them actually
believe they will be punished if they
vote to confirm this guy